foreign
not celebration
Ukraine marks one year of War by
honoring those who died to keep this
country free
the president Russia wanted to topple
still in charge
of
Ukrainian
an islamist
ium
Vina
Ukraine
a nation hurting
but defiant
[Music]
in the town of butcher where a mass
grave was found the pain runs deep
Russia's brief occupation here has left
permanent scars
this memorial wall in Keith is a
reminder that Ukraine has actually been
under attack since 2014.
that's when Russia first invaded and
annexed Crimea
it became a frozen Conflict at times all
but forgotten by many in the West
Vladimir Putin changed all that last
year galvanizing allies in a way that
hasn't been seen since the Cold War but
Russia isn't backing down and neither is
Ukraine it can only mean many more
painful days months possibly even years
in a sign of the president's growing
confidence he gave his first live press
conference since the full-scale War
Began do you believe that Ukraine can
achieve Victory on the battlefield or do
you believe that ultimately you're going
to have to negotiate maybe even
compromise maybe even talk to Vladimir
Putin
despite everybody seeing how they kill
torture and everything else they're not
even trying to hide their attacks why
not why not talk about nuclear issues
why not capture the nuclear power plant
why not take Iranian drones and kill
civilians and those civilians did not
have guns in their hands they had their
children
the Russians don't care near and seeing
the world this way do you think we
ukrainians can sit and negotiate with
all of this
each flag in the heart of the capital is
planted in memory of the Fallen
a growing Garden of grief
and sacrifice
Deborah Haynes Sky News Keith